a husband and wife now dead police are
describing this incident as a
murder-suicide now according to metro a
family member from another state
actually called them to inform them they
had gotten an email suggesting that a
man was going to kill himself this all
happened in the northeast part of the
valley outside of the moonlight terrace
property and that is where we find sally
jeremiah who spoke to neighbors right in
that area sally joins us live
brian and denise neighbors here
talk as they tell me this is a very
quiet and calm neighborhood and although
the coroner has yet to identify the
couple's names we do know both were in
their mid 50s
robert marcum has lived in the moonlight
terrace property since december of 2012
and says he's only seen police one or
two times in his neighborhood but when
he stepped out yesterday and saw the
police detectives an ambulance and the
corner he knew something was wrong once
he found out he felt for other family
members it's devastating to lose
your parents
on a natural situation
from natural causes
and
but
something like that
that don't go away for a long time metro
lieutenant ray spencer says the email
and notes left inside the condo suggests
the man murdered the woman and then took
his life
the man did die from a self-inflicted
gunshot wound now it's unclear how the
woman did die sally jaramillo live local
now sally